thank you so much
so as as has been said my name is Raquel
Bella's I'm rockbot on all of the things
and I am a senior software developer at
NPM Inc you may have heard of NPM you
use it to install all of your wonderful
JavaScript things I am honored to be
able to work there I can answer any
questions or give you stickers please
let me know I have answers and stickers
so let's get started on a scale of fist
to high-five where would you rate
yourself as a developer where where a
fist is I'm just figuring out this whole
JavaScript thing I think I know what a
variable is I'm learning about loops etc
etc - I have taught Brendan Eich
everything he knows right and you can
totally do the Fitbit thing if you want
like you could just be like you know I'm
like a three and a half or whatever cool
all right so you can play along - feel
free to play along okay cool cool all
right so I'm seeing like kind of like
beginning in the middle that's awesome
okay great what I'd like to talk about
today is how we go from here to here
because I think a lot of us who are kind
of here don't know what this path looks
like and I think those of us who are
here forgot what it was like to be here
so let's go through that whole process
yeah it's it's intense
I'm gonna use my personal story this is
not going to match everybody's butt I
think a lot of the elements are gonna be
the same so it all starts out the same
for all of us for whatever reason we say
I'm gonna start late in JavaScript or
insert technology of your choice but I'm
gonna start with JavaScript and whether
it's for a business reason or for
personal reasons we say okay this
JavaScript thing I'm gonna do it let's
do this yes totally for me I used to be
a roboticist I used to build robots you
know and I said to myself okay this is
kind of boring because the robots they
don't really have fun with me like we
don't get to party we don't get to like
talk about boys we don't they're just
kind of robots and so I decided I need I
need a little bit more people in my life
and I was living in Charlotte North
Carolina at the time and I said okay
well where's a cool place to work I
think the Internet is kind of cool let's
do that I mean I was a roboticist the
internet can't be that hard so I went
and talked to the CEO of the coolest
company in town and I said hi I'd really
like to work at your company what do I
need to do to work here
and he said learn node ok cool so I went
home and I was like I'm going to learn
node let's do this I'm going to build an
application that's how I learn etc etc
and I got nowhere right but this happens
to all of us right we have no idea what
we're doing because we don't know the
words that we need right so I knew
enough to say ok node it's a project as
a thing
go to the website nodejs org a
downloaded node and then I knew enough
about the command line to say well like
there's no application so I don't
double-click on anything I go to the
command line and I go and OD e enter and
what happens at that point you get this
carrot e thing it's like this little you
know it looks like this you see it also
in the JavaScript console when you go on
a browser and you're just looking at it
and it doesn't say anything you're like
ok so go geo enter what does it say this
is undefined you're like
okay this doesn't work for me at all I'd
no idea what I'm supposed to do I don't
have the words I don't have the
vocabulary to use to say how do i how do
I make this thing work right so what do
you do next you go online go to Google
Stack Overflow blog posts whatever and
you start looking for help
protip charity thing in node does not
produce any useful results there's just
nothing in there like again no
vocabulary no way for me to say I have
no idea what I'm doing I need help so
and then on top of that this was at the
beginning of 2012 when node was super
new like it I mean had been around for a
couple of years but it was still really
brand-new to the point where any
tutorials I found if it was more than
six six months old it was completely out
of date right like this is this isn't
even useful to me so whatever I still
try right I find some things and I start
playing around and I'm like oh this is
cool but I'm I care anything help so at
that point I realized I needed more
people in my life I needed to start
asking questions so into a local meetup
right like that's that's a great way to
start meeting people local developers in
your community and you can actually talk
to them and you can say so look here's
my terminal and OD e enter charity thing
and they go oh that's the repple yes yes
that's the read eval print loop that's
how we do all of our like on demand type
stuff what you really want is one a
separate file that then you can run node
file and then it runs and magic and
you're like oh my god why did nobody
tell me this didn't understand anything
but that's okay it's okay cuz you you go
and you talk to these people and you can
actually they have been there at least
enough that they can kind of read your
mind a little bit you're like and then
they're like yeah no repple that's the
word you're like cool and at the same
time I was trying to build this app and
I was like okay
I have this app and I want it to store
data and I know I need a database but
I've only ever used my sequel before
because that's what I used when I was
hacking on my wordpress blog is that
what I want to use and whatever you want
to say about databases and blah blah
blah at the time what I needed was
MongoDB and it was the perfect solution
again talking to people in person being
able to use words that didn't make any
sense to Google but made sense to people
made a huge difference so empowered with
all of this incredible knowledge I went
back to my app and I was like ok I'm
building this app I've got Mongoose and
I've got Express and how do i integrate
these things I don't know but now I have
keywords that I can ask Google so you
know you give some [ __ ] node there's
this wonderful module called Mongoose
and then they have a website and you can
like they've code samples and you're
like yes perfect code samples copy/paste
I expect magic to happen and no magic
happens and you're like well why isn't
this working and you're like I don't
know so you know you just don't have the
concepts fully integrated into
understanding how this is all supposed
to come together so you go back and
maybe you're your local meetup like they
only meet once a month or something like
that so you need to expand your group of
people to ask questions so what did we
do what did I do
I went onto IRC so if you don't know
what IRC is it's this amazing technology
that's been around apparently forever
but I didn't hear about it until 2012
and it was on IRC that I found the
Mongoose jeaious channel and I was like
hi I'm using your thing I think that's
the right thing for me but it's not
working in my stuff and they're like
alright send us your code and I said
what every single new person does I
copied and pasted all of my code into
IRC and it was just like 25 lines of
stuff and someone said oh god don't do
that again
and then I learned about a thing called
paste bin that was super useful and then
of course just sand etc etc but you know
I did I did the thing that everybody
does
I got very politely yells at I'm talk to
you that again okay so but still being
able to share my code with someone
someone else from a larger community
people who are from all over the world
not just my local community cuz you know
when your hacking at 2:00 a.m. sometimes
your friends aren't awake at 2:00 a.m.
but somebody in Germany might be and
that's awesome because then they can
kind of give you the speed back and they
give you they share more appropriate
vocabulary with you and then you
understand the concepts you understand
how things link together and it's really
awesome and so you take all this
knowledge and you're still gonna mess up
right this if you're not messing up
you're not doing engineering just FYI
this is how it works you do good you
mess up you succeed you know it's just
this cycle and you just kind of keep
moving forward but but this is a turning
point right because these concepts are
coming together enough and you've grown
your community enough to the point where
you're like okay whenever I have a
problem I might not know what it is
it might not know how to fix it but I at
least know what to ask where to ask and
who to ask right go and IRC go to your
friends go to your Meetup
whatever know exactly the magical
keywords to get the thing out of Google
Stack Overflow fantastic so now you can
actually keep moving forward and you're
like yes I got this I got this and you
find this point at which you're like wow
this is actually really cool this is so
fun I love this but I'm doing this on
the side I have like another job and
it's sucking all the life out of me
because I really just want to play with
node all the time maybe I can get a job
and node yes that's o'leary perfect idea
so you go and you I mean at some point
you get to the point where you are you
know enough information that you can be
a junior developer right and at that
point junior developers are useful
they're useful because you can tell them
exactly what to do and you don't have to
pay them very much money and you can
still move up move forward with your
product so you bring a junior developer
on board yeah you have to train them a
little bit but you get to train them
doing exactly what you want them to do
so from a junior developer perspective
your
oh my goodness now I have this
opportunity to get paid while I learn
awesome for me I got a job as an intern
I was I wasn't even a junior developer
yet I just got enough to be an intern I
was we're getting paid $500 a week which
is not very much at all and especially
for someone who was coming from robotics
it was kind of a blow to the system and
imploded the ego but I was like you know
what it's worth it this is gonna be okay
I'm gonna make it work
so fantastic you start working you start
learning and then you get to this point
where you're like well this is super fun
but I'm not exactly learning all the
things that I want to learn I'm learning
the things that my employers tell me to
learn and that's fine because at least
for me I was working at a consulting
company so I got to see a little bit of
PHP I got to see a little bit a node I
got to see a little bit of front-end
stuff I was convinced I was gonna be a
back-end developer cuz I did robotics
and then I was like hey CSS as annoying
as it can be he's actually really cool
because it's like see stuff and you get
to move things and floats and divs and
Wow and so at that point I kind of
transitioned to being more of a
front-end person but still lovin the
node and I kind of like to think of it
as like a buffet of learning you know
you go in and you just get a little bit
of each of these little things but it
still felt like I was missing something
I was like okay yes this is our stack at
this company but I know that there's
more I keep hearing these rumors of
these single page applications and all
this other stuff where do you go to
learn that where do you go to learn that
you come into one of these right this is
where you find out about all of those
things that you knew you're missing out
on something but you didn't know what it
was how many of you have learned
something new that you didn't realize
even existed since being here yeah
exactly
exactly so it's fantastic you get what
you're missing right
and it's like drinking from a firehose
it's like trying to get a little sip of
water and then it's just like right in
your face you're like oh my goodness
gracious but it's totally worth it
because then you get super excited about
all this stuff for me my very first
conference was node calm summer camp 20
12i I went to this conference hoping to
learn more about the event loop
apparently was gonna be to talk about
the event loop later I'm totally going
to that but at this conference I didn't
learn about the event loop I learned
about node core and domains and error
handling and I was like whoa whoa whoa I
just want to learn about just wanna
learn about the event loop please I'm
just new to this but there was another
really important aspect of going to a
conference I learned about people I met
people met all of these incredible
people that have completely changed my
life every conference I go to I meet new
people and it's incredible I become
really good friends with these people so
as a side note if there's nothing else
that you get out of this entire
conference nothing at all
because let's be real you can watch
these videos at home later there's
nothing else that you get out of this
conference walk away with at least five
Twitter handles five Twitter handles of
people that you are going to hang out
with and talk to you on Twitter if you
don't like Twitter use Facebook or email
I don't care but makes sure that you get
to know somebody else because these
people that are sitting in this room
with you they're gonna help you get your
job your next job they're gonna help you
when you have a bad day and they'll send
you funny cat gifs like super awesome
these people are really going to change
your life right here the ones that are
sitting right next to you and those of
you following along at home come to a
conference and let this like totally
transform you okay coming back so you're
talking these people you're at this
amazing conference and you're like
there's so much cool technology oh my
goodness I totally want to play with
this when do you do that what do you do
with all that cool technology you start
working on it on your own and yeah it
kind of stinks you can you don't always
get to take all the cool technology back
to work with you but let me just tell
you a little bit like there's a really
good opportunity to like if you can't
find the time to hack on things on your
own you become you expose yourself to a
whole bunch of other stuff right and
then you get to use all of these people
that you met at this conference where
you learn about all this stuff and you
and ask them hey can you take a look at
my code because here's the thing about
open source it's not it's not about
contributing to jQuery or node core it's
about taking literally your source and
you're opening it up you're just sharing
your stuff on github it doesn't need to
be anything like whoa magical like
life-changing it just needs me some code
show it to somebody let somebody else
say hey why did you do that what was
your what was your like inspiration for
this how did you figure that out that
was really cool like getting some
getting feedback on your code from
somebody else is super useful so for me
I was at this conference and I was like
talking to somebody and they said to me
hey used to robotics you know we're
missing a node we don't have like a
matrix module I was like that's true
there isn't a matrix model module and I
used to do robotics so matrices and I
were like this so I went ahead and
started hacking on stuff so you start
hacking on things and you're like I mean
look you're still gonna keep messing up
and you're still gonna like keep failing
and then you're gonna succeed and
they're gonna be these moments where
you're like oh my god and you're like
running around the office because you
know or your bedroom or whatever cuz
it's so exciting that you're getting it
but the point is that you're playing
with these things and you kind of
already is starting to get to know the
concepts and you're figuring all these
things out and it just starts to feel
really good cuz you're building
confidence in yourself you're like
actually I'm not a total newb anymore
this is awesome I mean you didn't teach
Brendan Eich everything he knows but
you're starting to get somewhere you
feel really good about it and these
concepts are just gelling really well
and you start to experiment a little bit
right like what happens when people get
a little too like confident they started
to get a little like experimental like
hey I wonder what happens if I do this
thing and it's kind of scary and it's
not always going to work but every once
in a while it will also at node comp I
met this guy named Chris Williams you
may have heard of him he
kind of started the whole Jay Escom
thing but he's also into robots and he I
remember being at this conference and I
was just talking to him and I was like
yeah you know yeah robots are kind of
cool I guess uh whatever and then and
then he damned me later and he was like
oh my god we you mean you used to do
robotics like full-time what are you
doing right now why are you in this
whole web thing we need to be working
together like I do this thing called
node BOTS it's not really a thing yet
but I want it to be I need your help and
so I said okay that sounds kind of crazy
maybe I can sew like afterwards as I'm
building this matrix module I was like
oh wait maybe this is an opportunity for
me to kind of segue into that that's
kind of cool and like these concepts are
so solid and I have all this extra
background information from what I used
to do like things that excite me just in
general and you keep experimenting and
you keep playing around and eventually
something starts to stick something
starts to stick real well and for me
this was my my vector module not very
many people use it but it's actually
like really cool how basically it's a
robotics focused matrix module
specifically for robots it's
specifically for matrices but I started
building on some really cool robots with
that and as you're building these things
you're like hey people are starting to
notice this stuff they start to use your
stuff and whatever it is that you're
building at some point it's gonna be
successful enough that people are going
to notice because people are gonna check
it out you're sharing your code right
you're putting it all out in open source
people are going to notice I'll never
forget the day I got and I am from a
tweet from Rick Waldron who I'd never
met at the time or by that point and if
you don't know who Rick Waldron is he's
on tc39 he's on the board of jQuery
he wrote Johnny Five which is like a
jQuery for hardware this is a guy that I
just like totally like bow down I'm like
oh my goodness you are you know
JavaScript
I don't know JavaScript but you know
JavaScript and you're saying that my
code is really awesome this is this is
wild like how did that happen how did I
get here and you know you completely
forget about all of the hard work that
you went through trying to get there but
from that point you start to realize
that as you're writing about your stuff
like you write blog posts you go to
workshops you lead workshops this stuff
that you didn't ever think was even
remotely possible you're standing up and
sharing your knowledge and people are
starting to think like you're an expert
they start asking you for help right
you're the one who they're like waiting
for on IRC like hey hey there you are
hey I'm all these questions oh my god
can you please help me hey here's all
with my code he's just please people
start to notice your expertise and
that's really exciting for me I started
doing node BOTS and nodebots completely
took off we had a workshop at JS conf
we had another workshop at the next day
s conf we had international node BOTS
day twice there are all of these
incredible events and more stuff is
coming but I want to hit home on this
one thing as you start to build
expertise as people start to notice all
of these things that you're contributing
other people outside of your necessary
little niche are going to start noticing
too because as you become more of an
expert as you start to actually know
what you're doing other people are gonna
want to start bringing you on board
I stopped interviewing at this point I I
don't really send my resume out anymore
I get other people calling me and it's
really like I don't mean to sound like
oh look at me I'm so awesome no what I'm
saying is other people are noticing that
you yes you are really quite good at
what you're doing
believe it or not and they start calling
you up and saying hey like maybe they're
Isaac shrewder the BDF a love note aka
the leader of the node project at the
time
saying hi I really like the things that
you're doing I'm starting this new
company called NPM Inc do you want to
come on board and you have this moment
where you're just like I'm a total noob
right and no you're not you're not a
noob anymore you've gone from here and
you're slowly making your way up you
know very slowly but you're there you're
you're you're sharing your stuff
everywhere everybody's already asking
you for help how is it so much harder of
an idea for somebody to say please come
onboard I want to pay you to work for me
and nobody else that's a pretty amazing
amazing opportunity and there gets to be
this point at which you realize despite
every single little piece of imposter
syndrome that sits in your head saying
you have no right to be up here you you
say that you've got to be up here
because if you don't share then who will
and you realize that you have received
so much from this community so very very
much they put up with your ridiculous
IRC logs and they put up with your silly
questions of charity thing and you
realize that you're not alone and you've
got to give back you have to give back
somebody needs to hear your story so I
want you to know that no matter where
you are on this scale seriously
anywhere you are and believe me at some
point you're gonna be like oh yeah I
know everything there is snow about
angular or ember or whatever and then
someone's gonna throw a brand new
framework at you and you're gonna start
at zero all over again and you're gonna
continually t'sit I have no idea what
I'm doing
I want you remember this one major thing
we're in this together
we're all in this together and wherever
you are we are with you I'm with you
you're with me we're in this together so
your stock and it's really important to
remember that javascript is so much more
than syntax
it's not about semicolons or tabs versus
spaces or any of that it's it's frankly
it's all of us thank you very much